you know at this point in time i'm
starting to get the impression that when
it comes to writing villains trauma
might as well be embodied by that thanos
line
i am
inevitable
[Music]
yep we're talking about writing tropes
again and this time i'm going to be
talking about how trauma is being used
when it comes to
justifying villainy so
there is a movie that kind of
got me to the point where i really
wanted to this is actually something
i've been thinking about for a while but
um there is a movie that made me go okay
i need to pull the trigger on this and
that was
i would say spoiler alert but at this
point if you cared you would have seen
it because it's out on streaming now
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and what they did with wanda now
they were a little tricky with some of
what they did i'll come back to that but
the thing overall is that they took a
character who was a hero
injected her with sufficient trauma to
have her just be the flat out villain
and i don't mean the morally gravel and
i mean a freaking horror movie villain
now
regardless of what you think about what
happened in that movie or indeed what
you think about any of the movies i'm
going to end up bringing up over the
course of this
having trauma
related to someone who is a villain and
drawing some kind of connection to their
behavior
from that trauma
that is not inherently bad as with any
and all tropes that i talk about it can
be used well it can be used poorly at
this point my issue is much more with
the pattern and the reliability with
which trauma is used to frame
villainy or sometimes even
the worst actions of heroes
so let's start to get into some examples
of what i'm talking about i suppose we
might as well kind of get wanda out of
the way here
so
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness wanda is as i said she is a
horror movie villain thank you sam raimi
she is
murderous
she does not care about collateral
damage and she is on a quest to try and
find somewhere in the multiverse
versions of her children her sons who
are still alive so that she can have
them again and she does not care what
gets torn apart in the process and i
mean that very truly she does not care
whatever stage she's at
in her own process here
the point at which you might have
questioned the degree to what she was
taking things is long in the past
she gives people brief warnings and in
spite of your
hypocrisies and insults i have begged
you to safely get out of my way
but she's more than content to just
tear people apart
if she feels that they are preventing
her from getting her goals she is
a really bad person in this
and she had been a hero
how did they get there
well basically they gave wanda a one-two
punch of trauma she's kind of got trauma
stacked on trauma
so more immediate to doctor strange to
the multiverse of madness was the events
of wanda vision the ending of which
had her
effectively have to give up and
relinquish her invented family which
included a resurrected vision hang on to
him i'll come back to him and her two
aforementioned sons in the continuity
and the reality in the universe that she
lives in they never really existed
however once she got access to something
called the darkhold i'll also come back
to that she was able to start spanning
looking across the multiverse to find a
universe in which those two boys
did exist and she was prepared to go to
any length
to have them in her life again it's
actually uh kind of a little bit the
same motivation to give kingpin in into
the spider-verse but that's neither here
nor there the execution and the kind of
villain that she is is very different
from him motivation similarities aside
but as i said vision uh
the offense of one division itself are
already spawning off of trauma from her
well not just her losing vision
she killed him
in an effort to keep
thanos from getting a hold of the
infinity gem that was in his head
so she killed him
but it didn't matter
thanos got the gem anyways
so not only did she lose him
she went through the pain and the agony
of killing him
and it didn't
matter and he's still dead
so you had trauma resulting in wand
division and then you had your
double-dose trauma resulting in
multiverse of madness i keep want to say
mountains of madness that's a different
thing now
when i did my review in the break room
of geeks of that movie i did complain
about the fact that they basically
loaded wanda up with trauma in order to
make her a villain
and so many people
were quick to launch into my comics and
go oh but it's not just trauma it's the
darkhold the darkhold corrupted her so
the darkhold is just it's an evil book
it's the necronomicon for all intents
and purposes and she comes into
possession of that at the end of one
division it's actually one of the worst
aspects of one division i did a whole
video on how that thing badly falls
apart uh by the end and it's now
actually immensely clear that the only
reason that happened was to get the dark
hold in her hand and facilitate the
extreme degree of villainy that she goes
into but i'm actually planning to later
on devote an entire video about the ways
in which the interconnectedness of the
mcu is actually starting to hinder the
storytelling but that's got to be a
topic for another day
in any case
the thing about the darkhold
both the film itself and the defenders
of the film can argue all day long about
how
the degree to which she took things and
her willingness to use violence
was
pushed forward by the darkhold think of
it a little bit like
the one ring
in the lord of the rings it's pushing
her towards
the worst
possible uh course of action
here's the thing though
she already knew the dark hole was
dangerous
it was in possession
of somebody who was using it for evil
she already knew the thing was dangerous
she chose to use it
because she thought it would help her
get her boys back
so you can argue to me all day long
that the darkhold made her worse but i
would point out the only reason she has
that
is as a response
to her trauma
so it still
comes back
to the trauma
that's the primary example i'm going to
lead in with i'm going to cite a few
others and then i'm going to start to
talk about why this is kind of a problem
for me because i i have no doubt some
people are always already starting to
ask well like
why does why does this have to be a bad
thing what's your actual issue with that
so like you've made your case as to why
trauma led to one's villainy but what's
the problem with that
we'll get there let me give you a couple
of other examples so that i'm not just
building off just the one and what i'm
initially going to start with and we'll
talk some of the grayer instances later
on but initially i'm going to talk about
the instances where
the trauma leads pretty directly
to the villainy the things that they do
as villains are almost a direct response
to the initial trauma sticking within
the mcu
zemo
zemo's entire thing being the villain of
civil war wow
being the uh person who initiates the
problems in civil war
they kind of got
multiple layers going on there but as
far as he is concerned his entire reason
for going after the avengers seeking to
tear them apart
planning assassinations murdering people
torturing them like these are things he
knew how to do but he is all doing this
as revenge for the loss of his family it
took me two days
until i found their bodies and the
avengers
they went home
his entire plan
is a direct reaction to that he wouldn't
be doing any of this if his family was
still alive it is a direct response to
his trauma you could make an argument
that he wasn't that good a guy before
but he was a passive not that good guy
before
this made him an active villain getting
off of marvel we can go to dc batman's
got a few of these
one you've got harvey dent now the exact
nature of harvey psychosis actually
varies by interpretation in some
interpretations he already had some
degree of personality disorder possibly
did possibly uh some other form of
instability and that the scarring that
happened to him from having acid thrown
in his face simply
just pushed him at the far end of
something he already had you have other
versions where he's actually a pretty
decent and normal guy until the scarring
turns him into
the coin flipping gangster that he is a
trauma powerful enough to create an
alternate personality leaves the victim
in a world where normal rules of right
and wrong no longer apply exactly
in either case even when
there is some underlying psychosis that
basically gets made worse that's still
that event it's still that trauma
that makes him
this specific iteration of villainy
two-face exists in the form that he does
and operates in the manner in which he
does
because of the trauma of his facial
disfigurement and the loss that came
with that
loss of lots of things his
livelihood his career his looks his
marriage well depending on what version
it cost him his marriage anyways
again fairly direct response to trauma
another solid example from batman mr
freeze
mr freeze
is a villain
as a direct response to the death of his
wife well i say direct there's actually
kind of two steps so his initial actions
and things he's doing in his uh his
looking into everything uh in relation
to the preservation of life through
freezing and things like that has to do
because his wife is dying now he doesn't
strictly go into villainy directly as a
result of that but when
he can't save her and the reason again
will vary sometimes he gets into a crime
to fund his attempts to continue to find
a cure sometimes there is an outside
force that like you know does the
classic shove him back into his own
thing of chemicals stuff
but again the trauma of the loss of his
wife sometimes combined with initial
trauma from
an assault or somebody else sort of
forcing something onto him
the way he operates and everything he
does
is a result of his trauma
at this point the standard way to depict
mr freeze is as someone who engages in
criminality
to the end of trying to revive his wife
and figure out how to do that so no
matter what else he does
his response to the trauma of loss of
her is his core motivation it's why he
does what he does dc actually has a
tendency to do this a lot and they also
have one of the most infamous examples
from the comics if you know the uh the
comic books from the 90s which that was
not a good time for comics
so
hal jordan's
city because like it it was pretty
typical uh in dc for various heroes to
basically have a city that they
protected superman had metropolis batman
had gotham
they put oliver queen a few places black
canary was in portland for a while but
that that's kind of the thing they do
whereas uh marvel just pours everybody
into new york
but
with hal
his city was coast city
and that city got
obliterated
completely
and hal
lost it
now i know some of the continuity folks
are going to be shouting at me about the
retconned explanation for that and i'll
acknowledge it in a minute but let's
deal with how this was presented at the
time this story happened
that loss
that trauma was so great
that when he initially tried to use the
powers of the ring and the green lantern
battery to undo the damage and bring co
city back and the guardians of the
universe said he can't do that
he
went
bonkers
he was killing green lanterns left and
right hoarding their rings making
himself more and more and more powerful
they made him a flat out super villain
like a cosmic scale super villain
he had to be put down and killed
as a result of this
and this was one of the shining
heroes
of the dc universe who had been around
since the 60s
and the trauma broke him and made him
the kind of villain that can't be
allowed to live
now yes as i said there were later
retcons to have him kind of possessed by
a being called parallax which was
actually the name he had adopted for
when he went full villain because you
know
they still want to publish green lantern
books and they had someone else having
that mantle actually had a couple of
people having that mantle but they did
change his name to parallax and then
later on
parallax became a name assigned to sort
of this
fear demon for lack of a better way to
put it uh that had and it was retconned
that it possessed how but that is again
a wretch con
original intent was
the trauma
broken
now while i've cited superhero related
stuff so far it's not exclusive to them
i can pull you a couple of examples from
horror movies as well
candyman
i'm gonna stick with the original on
this i didn't see the remake and i
haven't seen the sequels but the
candyman
as a vicious
murdering ghost
exists at all
as a response to an
insanely traumatic wrong and death that
was instilled upon him but what he does
why he does it and his
operating procedure his mo
that's all direct result of
the trauma
of what killed him back in the day or
another instance
carrie white
from
carrie
she's got a little bit less a single
point of trauma she had a single
breaking point but she is one of those
characters who's kind of had layered
trauma because uh what we see of her
home life it is very clear just living
with her mother has been incredibly
traumatic the way she is treated at
school has been continually traumatic
and then there is that one final moment
of having the pig's blood dropped on her
where she snaps
she massacres
the school dance
in response to
accumulated trauma
that has finally boiled over
okay so those are some i think um
reasonable examples of trauma being core
to the creation of someone as a villain
at all
like the reason that they do what they
do is incredibly tied to their trauma
so why is this a problem
because
i do think it is a bit even though i
understand why it happens
so it happens because
you want to give depth
to your villains well
there's a i would say actually at this
point almost excessive need to give
depth to villains some of the most
effective and memorable villains in
movie or entertainment history
are very simplistic and effectively have
no backstory maybe they have trauma we
don't know
heath ledger's joker
maleficent before the live-action film
which i'll also be coming back to but
you used to be able to have villains
like that that's not really a thing
anymore
there's this notion that giving them a
backstory explaining why they do what
they do
makes them more
realistic
sometimes
uh more understandable gives them more
depth occasionally it's even used as a
way to maybe sympathize with them on
some points
and that's not a bad goal in and of
itself
but the recurrent use of focusing trauma
because
here's the thing
a bit like
how
movies especially are really bad
about using mental illness as a reason
why someone is dangerous despite the
fact that in reality the vast majority
of people with mental illness are
not dangerous or if they're dangerous at
all is to themselves not to others and
they're far more likely to be the
victims of violence than the
perpetrators and yet
the
repeated use of mental illness as
a
background feature of villainy
gets used anyways so regardless of the
reality
this keeps getting a focus and similarly
so trauma because the simple reality is
once you hit a certain point in your
life
everybody has trauma
not everybody has the same type of
trauma not everybody responds to trauma
in the same ways
but i'm 40.
when you hit my age
you've had some trauma
you've had loss
you've had pain
and you didn't turn into a super villain
hopefully if there are any super
villains watching this like i i actually
i'm not sure that's the audience i'm
trying to court
but
while it is true
the old adage that
you know a bully
was probably bullied themselves and that
abusers
tend to have been abused themselves
that's true
[Music]
but not all abused people then become
abusers
and not that movies or television are
intentionally trying to send that
message they're not it's just that is
the subtextual message of the pattern
which they send so while i don't think
it's actually unreasonable to assume
that the vast majority of villainous
characters
if you were to dig through and do a full
character history they've probably got
trauma so does everybody else
but it's with the villains that that
trauma gets highlighted
and brought special attention to
when it comes to heroes
you will get trauma sometimes
but
it comes from a fairly limited pool
of acceptable forms of trauma ptsd for
heroes has actually kind of been in
vogue for a little bit
uh now that has become an acceptable
thing
but
when trauma is highlighted even for
heroes
it's almost always
tied to
what is considered a character failing
or fault
or mistake
that's something else i am going to come
back to
but that's
my
big issue here
yes
i don't doubt all these villainous
characters and others i'm going to talk
about a little bit
have trauma i'm sure they do
but what is the actual benefit to the
story
to point that out
or to have that trauma so directly
cause and effect and impact their
actions as a villain and i don't just
mean like some of the things they do i
mean
the fact that they are a villain at all
by tying it into trauma
by highlighting the traumatic moment in
which they became villains
sends a message
that trauma creates villainy
but it doesn't
but highlighting it in the way that they
do and almost never bringing up trauma
in relation to a villain unless you're
doing some kind of origin story moment
for here's the point which they became a
villain
means that's still the message you're
sending whether you mean to or not
now there are ways to balance this and
as i said there are some other
characters who i want to bring up
because these uh unlike the ones i cited
earlier which are i think
pretty clear cases of trauma directly
leads to villainy
what you can also run into is trauma is
in the mix for their villainy
but may or may not be the reason they're
a bad person it may simply impact
the specific
plans they are making but maybe they
wouldn't have been a good person anyway
so like
some examples of that the backstory
elements we get on a character like say
crease from
uh the cobra kai show on netflix
there's some traumatic stuff in there
but he kind of already had the building
blocks of a not great guy
killmonger from black panther i think
another decent example he's clearly got
trauma from the death of his father
and you could even make an argument that
his father's death is what led him down
the path of joining the military
but that is far enough removed as least
as far as time goes that you get the
distinct sense that
what kind of work he did in the military
what he was asked to do in the military
did a lot to shape
the kind of person he is as well and
while the death of his father is
impacting his decision to go after
wakanda specifically
i think even without that trauma
he still would not have been a good
person
not a pleasant person
and he still would have been dangerous
similarly with nebula um so she
obviously is another character with
continuing trauma from being thanos's
daughter but you also see her fight to
break away from that and
once she is not in his presence anymore
you realize how much being directly
there with him is sort of focusing in on
her trauma because her trauma is
basically standing right there once she
gets away from him she is start she
starts to be able to break some of those
patterns a bit more so trauma's in the
mix
but it is not sort of creating a world
in which that trauma has tainted her and
now she's villain forever it's like no
we can move uh in a better direction if
we can get you out of that situation
i would actually throw in the killing
joke uh in with this because while we
in that uh i'm gonna go with the comic
don't watch the movie in that original
comic there is an explanation offered
for
why the joker is the way he is beyond
just you know having his skin bleached
by toxic chemicals
and that origin
is trauma the way the joker himself puts
it
one bad day drove him mad and made him
what he is
i'm putting it here rather than in the
trauma leads directly to villainy
category though because the overall
framing of that book
was intelligent enough to say yeah that
might not actually be true a because we
have the possibility thrown out that
that backstory isn't even really what
happened
but more importantly
the outcome of the rest of the book
refutes that
batman refutes that
he says to the joker
no
not everyone breaks because of one bad
day
maybe it was just
you it wasn't your trauma it's you
and
that i think is one of the reasons why
that is
a pretty well-loved book
despite a lot of the problems that go on
particularly with the use of barbara
gordon and batgirl it ain't a flawless
book but i think that elements still
handle really well and it's a case where
trauma's put into the mix
but it never allows it to be the reason
why the joker's like this that idea is
challenged
head on some other examples uh not too
long ago i finished up a re-watch of the
show farscape which i did a podcast on
with jessie gender that was a lot of fun
and the villain in that scorpius who is
one of the all-time sci-fi villains oh
scorpius is
so good he's also got a lot of trauma
and while that trauma helped shape his
determination and certainly some of his
motivation
it's not the only thing that drives him
it is the source of a major part of his
motivation in terms of going after this
other race of beings called the scarins
but in terms of the way he chooses to
operate
the degree to which he is prepared to
put
the hero john crichton and his friends
through absolute hell
in order to get what he wants
that's not because of his trauma
that is how he has chosen to forge a
path for himself because scorpius is
very much a character
in control of his life
despite how few free choices he had
early on
but even in these instances where i'm
saying like it's more in the mix than
the direct cause
it still can get iffy though again
largely having to do with framing and
how the information of that trauma is
brought across to the audience
and it's almost always offered up at a
point in the story in which it is
serving as some kind of explanation as
to why even if it's just tossed off
dialogue like with the jesse eisenberg
version of lex luthor and batman v
superman in the middle of his freaking
villain monologue towards the end
mentioning no man in the sky intervened
when i was a boy to deliver me from
daddy's fists and abominations
why are you including that i mean at
this point he's been acting as the
villain we've known he's the villain for
a while we've seen his plans go into
action
what's the point of that addition
it doesn't inform
anything
yet it's there anyways
as if bringing up his trauma
is explanation in and of itself even
when it doesn't directly tie in
it metaphorically ties in at best
but why is that there
so let's talk about some instances where
trauma is used
to explain a character's villainy
where i think it does actually work
because the instances i've set it up to
now well i said you can still like these
there's nothing wrong with liking these
my problem as always is with the pattern
less than the specific instances most of
the time
i still think they did wanda dirty but
regardless there are some characters and
sometimes when we get
the specifics of
how they became who they are
and it can even include trauma
but i wouldn't complain about it i've
got three main examples to cite here i'm
gonna do them in
um
ascending order of mainstreamness so
let's start with a show that i recently
finished on netflix with my kiddo
kippo in the age of wonderbeasts
by the end the primary villain of that
is a woman named amelia
she is a scientist she is someone who is
dedicated to this idea of helping
humanity reclaim
the surface world after having been
stuck in bunkers while
massive mutinous animals are running
amok on the surface
and there was a really interesting
subversion
because she gets set up
to have a tragic backstory there's even
little hints
about you know how her father
pushed her too hard or whatever
and while that may potentially be true
there's never a moment where it's like
and there it is
that's where she became
the person willing to go to the like she
does the person who doesn't care about
other people
it's subverted because she doesn't
actually get
specific trauma a specific
traumatic backstory depicted
what we ultimately find out through the
flashbacks is
that's just who she is
she's that kind of person
largely on her own again if you were to
chart out every single moment of her
life yeah there's probably trauma that
contributed but as far as this story was
concerned
this is just who she is
this isn't a response to a thing that
happened
and that was actually important to the
story
because she was the one villain
that they couldn't talk down
and
find a way to connect with
because
this is just fundamentally who she is as
a human being
another example
paranorman
this is a fantastic movie this my
personal favorite leica movie
uh but i like this a lot and there is
this whole thing with a witch's curse
and it raises zombies and there's all
sorts of twists along the way in terms
of what the threat actually is and by
the end we do find out like there was a
witch
there is a witch's curse
but the witch isn't some old hag
that cursed the town
the witch is a young girl
who the townspeople were afraid of
and they killed her
and ultimately
she's not even really the villain
the trauma itself is kind of the villain
because she has gone however long like
100 200 300 years
of time
of everyone just assuming that she was
the monster that the history books
recorded her as
and nobody
ever
tried
to reach out to her
until norman does
at the very end
the wrong committed against her
is much more the villain than she is
and she's not irredeemable
as a result
it's just nobody
ever
tried
and then the final example i'm going to
use and the most well-known i'm sure
syndrome from the first incredibles
movie what i like about syndrome
is he would probably actually argue
that his villainy is a result of the
trauma of being rejected by his
childhood hero mr incredible
here's why this works though
his villainy is so out of proportion
to what it was that happened to him
he was an annoying snot-nosed little kid
who was legitimately causing danger he
meant well yes he meant well yes he was
trying to help but he was causing danger
he was distracting mr incredible and he
made a situation worse and when mr
incredible said you're a kid go home
he becomes a super villain
that
works because that is not
an understandable reaction to what
happened to him
somebody who reacts that extremely to
again i'm not gonna say a completely
untraumatic thing having your hero
basically tell you to piss off
probably a little traumatic but to
become a super villain as a result of
that basically is a way of saying the
trauma is his excuse for how he ended up
the way he is
he made choices
this is not something that happened to
him
this is just the moment that he
decided to go after mr incredible
specifically but again this reaction is
so out of proportion i cannot believe a
world in which
buddy does not become
a deeply horrible person regardless
so it's not his trauma
it's him
now you'll notice in those examples
trauma is frequently still present well
it wasn't with amelia but that was a
direct subversion but there's still
trauma there
but there are other things at play
that make it clear that while the trauma
may be a factor
it's not the reason
it's not the core true reason
why
these people are so dangerous
and again
this might not be such a problem if we
didn't feel the need to do these deep
back stories on villains like sometimes
you get really good stuff out of it but
then
like i'll come back to maleficent
what is gained
by taking someone who was clearly
gleeful in just being the bad guy
that was part of what made her
amazing
and now she's a
metaphorical
uh sexual assault
victim what does that add
i mean it's the basis for that entire
first movie and it enabled them to make
her into an anti-hero but again
why would you do that
and why would you use trauma to do it
i also mentioned uh how even when trauma
shows up for heroes
it's often framed
as a reason for
some of their mistakes
their character flaws and their worst
decisions i'll stick to the mcu with
this one because they kind of had the
best examples at least that i could
think of you've got drax in the first
guardians of the galaxy he's on a
mission to have his revenge against
ronan that is a direct result of his
trauma of losing his family
he brings ronin to them
in a hope to have a one-on-one fight
he causes massive problems by doing that
he puts so many people in danger as a
result of a choice he makes because of
his trauma
tony stark
in civil war i know i talked about zemo
but tony is honestly kind of the
secondary villain
that final confrontation
at the very end
when tony
and cap
come to
full-on blows that's because cap is
protecting bucky
and tony knows that bucky killed his mom
and he says flat out to steve i don't
care
he killed my mom
the intellectual part of his brain
has literally been overridden
by the lingering pain of the trauma of
that loss
and
it is framed
as a bad thing
it's used as a reason
why a hero
makes a big mistake and a bad call
and you want to see the most extreme
version of this at least in terms of
consequences
quill
quills loss
of his mother
at a young age
and then later on
in terms of finding out about his father
and putting so much stake
into this
found family that he has
that
is why
he can't just
keep on top of his emotions
when he finds out that thanos killed
gamora
they had a plan to deal with thanos it
was working
it stopped working
because peter lost control and the
reason peter quill
lost control
is because it dredged up
all
of his pain and his
baggage and his trauma
because we know
that triggering that
is a powerful thing for him it's what
snapped him out of siding with his
father when he found out his father
killed his mom
oh
but
while there
maybe the memory of that trauma helped
refocus him in infinity war
it instead caused him to make a mistake
that led to the obliteration of half of
the universe
now
i don't want to wrap up here without
pointing out that
rare as it can be
sometimes
sometimes
trauma isn't used to motivate villainy
sometimes it's used to motivate heroism
now
many heroes have trauma as part of their
background but that's not quite what i'm
after i mean heck a lot of superheroes
the fact that they have superpowers at
all often comes with something traumatic
happening
but i'm going to cite you two examples
where the trauma
actually led to them being a hero
at all
not just and it's not even about powers
forget powers
them as people
the example that
is less clean now than it used to be
is batman
because the original motivating factor
for batman
was that he lost his parents
and he made a pledge
that no one
else would ever
lose what he lost in the way he lost it
never again
not on his watch
that's why he patrols the streets that's
why he cares about street-level crime
because street-level crime is what took
his family from him
now more recent incarnations have
muddied that a bit with a higher degree
of uh this idea of obsession on revenge
or just making batman a less flatly
heroic figure than he used to be but you
know i did a video on the fact that
batman's not allowed to be fun anymore
uh because you know
the loss of his parents used to be what
pushed him down the decision to be hero
now it's like the source of
everything good and bad about him
so i think at this point a better
example is probably spider-man
because if you remember spider-man's
origin he gets bitten by the spider
and his first impulse
once he realizes he has powers
is to
use it to make money use it for his own
ends his own
uh betterment of his life selfish
reasons
the reason he's a hero
is because of the death of uncle ben
ben dying
and peter realizing
he could have prevented that but his
inaction
earlier that same day
led to a series of events that resulted
in his
uncle dying
that
is why with great power comes great
responsibility
that was the moment that solidified
that
him having the ability to help
means
that he kind of has to
because peter can help and he could have
helped he could have stopped that robber
that burglar
from running away with the money but he
was angry
and he was selfish and he didn't and
that same man later killed his uncle
and that trauma
him who he is
it is what motivates him and keeps him
on the path of being a hero despite
dealing with a lot more trauma since
then holy crap
fans of spider-man will talk about the
peter parker luck cause
good grief
but that is a case where trauma
isn't used as a reason to explain
somebody's failings
but somebody's positive qualities
somebody's
admirable
values
trauma in a character's backstory
is a tool
like any tool
i think right now it's being overused
on the assumption that giving an insight
into a character's trauma because as i
kind of alluded to before
literally every character's gonna have
some
there's this assumption that
an insight into the trauma deepens the
character makes it better well
not always
does that knowledge of this character
actually enhance the story
or
is it
just there
to add
fake depth
there's nothing inherently wrong with
using trauma as a way to explain a
character being who they are even a
villain
but
i'd like to see it start to be done with
a bit more restraint
in terms of
as opposed to
becoming the default
the reason
the explanation
what went wrong well this traumatic
thing happened ah yes yes
yes trauma would cause them to want to
destroy half the universe
i'm sorry what
no we've all got it
and
we don't all become super villains i
mean
you hang around the wrong parts of the
internet it can seem that way sometimes
but i promise we're not
what are your thoughts
on the use of trauma
as an explanation or a vehicle
for villainy whether it be as part of a
backstory for a villain to as giving an
explanation of why they are the way they
are everything from you know the loss of
a loved one with someone like darth
vader or even hannibal lecter they
freaking did that
or whether it be a reason to take a
previously heroic character
like wanda
or hal jordan and turn them evil
again turning it
on trauma
and there are plenty more examples of
that especially from comics they did
that with hawke
they did that with mary marvel
several times
but however it's used what are your
thoughts on the
trauma to villainy pipeline
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
patreon is what enables me to do this as
my living
and any amount you are able to
contribute to that is of immense
assistance but even if you can't
all of the other stuff that
every youtuber asks you to do does
actually help
like share subscribe the bell sure why
not you could do that
but the thing i really want you to
remember
is that no matter what you've been
through
that does not make you the villain
your path is not set
by your trauma
and you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right i've got thanks to give for my
patreon supporters robin moore zubin
fulla turak the thing that goes doink in
the anime oliver b linda walters
imudelki the oatha boyd tt for nobulax
the poodle zach idoln tracy scrabbit
angry casper
toku bl whovian adam rdl taylor shane
ross shayla gourley and brendan larose
the rats and i thank you
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]